[Musique]
vous en avez désormais l'habitude tous
les lundis les sur ce plateau michael et
demi d'euros bonsoir monsieur sport de
cette rédaction alors vous décrypter
pour nous elle les résultats du week-end
dans lé département beaucoup d'émotion
notamment écran baseball découvrir
montigny-le-bretonneux commence par du
baseball les cougars de monti le
bretonneux n'ont pas réussi à décrocher
le premier titre de champion de france
de leur histoire désigne montants ont
perdu ce samedi le troisième match de
leur série contre rouen sur le score de
2 à 0
les cougars pourront se consoler en se
disant qu'ils ont tout simplement
réalisé le plus beau parcours de
l'histoire du club
ils sont également qualifiés pour la
coupe d'europe une première pour
montigny le bretonneux
on a déjà hâte de les retrouver la
saison prochaine les oreilles on les
retrouvera tout de suite après ce
journal dans le 7-8 sport votre émission
puisqu'ils viendront le deux ensemble
sur le plateau toute l'équipe sera
présente y aura du monde sur ce plateau
de tv 78 on continue mais quelle part du
rugby là encore des émotions
direction le championnat de division
honneur versailles n'en finit à plus de
gagner ce dimanche les versailles en
entendant j'ai leur quatrième victoire
de la saison en autant de matches en
s'imposant à domicile 26 à 9 contre le
rc paris 15 avec quatre essais inscrits
on écoute les réactions on a eu un petit
passage en si peu un temps faible en fin
de première période on a remis les
bouchées doubles en début le début de
deuxième mi temps et sait gérer pas que
ce sens force est là on a few confiance
confiance en nos forces on est au dessus
dans le sens où on a confiance on a
confiance en nos forces et quand on
arrive à jouer simplement on peut
arriver à mettre en difficulté n'importe
qui on est très contents très satisfait
l'engagement dégâts et de ce qu'ils
produisent à l'entraînement donc on est
sur la bonne la bonne voie une belle
ambiance en tout cas sur ces images les
gorilles avec cette victoire les joueurs
de la cité royale s'envole déjà au
classement l'équipe compte quatre points
d'avancé sur clichy après seulement
quatre journées dans ce championnat de
la division honneur du football et et de
la coupe de france va-t-on pouvoir
continuer à arriver avec les club
yvelinois
on peut dire oui grégory mais c'est
quand même un peu contrastée cinquième
tour ou donc contrasté pour les
yvelinois les principaux résultats du
département ça passe pour verser qui
s'impose 3 1 sur le terrain de saint
germain sentry poissy sera également
présent au 6e tour les pisciacais ont
dominé lille
rigard gand 3 2 après prolongations
c'est terminé pour ou et qui s'incline
aux tirs au but contre ivry
même scénario pour les mureaux sur le
terrain de saint maur epône se fait
sortir par bobigny 3 à 0 et conflans
perd contre fleury mérogis 2 à 1
merci michael pour ce tour d'horizon